les journalistes et notamment les grand
reporter en décidément l'honneur du
cinéma depuis quelques mois avec un
nouveau confrère en la personne de lino
ventura qui campe un reporter plus
musclée que la plupart de ceux que nous
connaissons ici il est le héros de la 7e
cible de claude pinoteau lino ventura
qui est aussi peu bavard que ces héros
mais qui sait quand même confié à france
roche voici quatre ans qui n'avait pas
donné des mythes et raciaux dans la
septième cible lino ventura joue le rôle
d'un homme presque tranquille en butte à
des menaces et des agressions auxquelles
il répond avec vigueur vous allez voir
mais ce à quoi ils n'aiment pas ce sont
les intérêts au gabon jours de ça et
d'une et je suis très mal à l'aise je
vois pas pourquoi je me torturais et
puis aussi j'ai été un petit peu échaudé
par des des ne serait ce que par des
interviews que j'ai vu deux mois que je
n'ai jamais donné
vous avez tourné une cascade dans ce
film et quand on se trouve dans une
situation comme celle là on a envie
d'aller de plus en plus forts de plus en
plus loin ça dépend avec qui c'est vrai
qu'avec rémy avec remy julienne je peux
je peux je peux aller très loin parce
que j'ai une confiance aveugle en lui
disant je veux dire c'est surtout ça qui
compte c'est d'avoir confiance avec qui
vous faites ça même avec un simple
accessoiristes qui vous dit je vais te
faire péter une mine dans les pieds et
ça dépend qui avec certains
accessoiristes que je connais qui sont
des vieux d'élus au renard de ce métier
je m'approche rey à dix centimètres de
la ligne parce que je sais que je ne
risque rien merrick d'autres avec
d'autres tubes approcherait pas il faut
aussi avoir confiance dans le partenaire
avec lequel on se bat benoît était
boxeur est aussi dans le réalisateur et
l'acteur lino tourne pour la troisième
fois avec claude pinoteau et jean loup
dabadie
jean loup me connaît parfaitement il
sait exactement quels sont vos réactions
et mes colères mes joies mes reer ou pas
je veux dire mon côté taciturne ours
enfin tout ce que vous voulez et tout ce
monde quoi on affuble donc c'est déjà
plus facile je pense pour quelqu'un pour
un écrivain d'écrire pour quelqu'un
qu'il connaît bien
allez c'est que toi tu l'as faisait
jouir et moi vois on vous dit les choses
dont on affuble alors vous n'êtes pas du
tour si vous n'avez pas de colère vous
n'êtes pas chanceux si quand même un peu
menteur